♪
>>> USED TO LOVE THIS SONG.
NEW YORK CITY, THE LARGEST
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS SENDING HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS, KIDS, BACK TO
CLASSROOMS TODAY.
IN SOME CASES, THE FIRST TIME,
IN MORE THAN A YEAR.
THAT'S GREAT.
MEDICAL OLIVER SPOKE TO BILL De
BLSIO ABOUT THE DECISION AFTER
MONTHS OF CRITICISM FROM BOTH
SIDES OF THE ISSUE.
MEG, GOOD MORNING.
THIS IS A BIG MILESTONE FOR A
LOT OF FAMILIES.
>> Reporter: GAYLE GOOD MORNING.
IT'S A HUGE DAY.
NEW YORK CITY HIGH SCHOOLS ARE
REOPENING.
THEY HAVE ABOUT 500, AND NEARLY
HALF OF THEM WILL RETURN IN
PERSON FIVE DAYS AWEEK.
ONE BIG REASON IS THE TESTING
PROTOCOLS IN PLACE.
WE SPAOKE TO A SENIOR WHO
COMMUTES FROM QUEENS TO
STUYVESANT HIGH SCHOOL.
SHE CANNOT WAIT TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THE REMAINDER OF
HER HIGH SCHOOL CAREER.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE YOU FEEL,
THAT YOU'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
BASICALLY SALVAGE THE REST OF
YOUR HIGH SCHOOL?
>> I FEEL LIKE IT'S A GIFT OF
TIME AND LIKE RETURNING BACK TO
NORMAL.
I DO WANT TO BECOME A NORMAL
HIGH SCHOOLER AGAIN.
>> Reporter: MERIL MOUSOOM IS
GOING BACK TO SCHOOL FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN A YEAR.
THE 17-YEAR-OLD SENIOR SAYS
WHILE SHE'S NERVOUS, SHE'S
STRUGGLED WITH REMOTE LEARNING.
HAVE YOU BEEN LONELY?
>> DEFINITELY.
MY PARENTS ARE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS, I'M THE ONE WHO HAS TO
BE ALONE ALL THE TIME.
AND IT'S FELT EXTREMELY
ISOLATING.
>> Reporter: IF YOU COULD TELL
MAYOR BILL De BLASIO ONE THING,
WHAT WOULD IT BE?
>> I WOULD TELL MAYOR De BLASIO
TO UNIVERSITY IN OUR CHILDREN
BECAUSE WE TRULY ARE THE FUTURE.
AND THIS GENERATION IS
STRUGGLING MENTALLY, THEN THE
FUTURE WILL BE AT STAKE.
>> Reporter: THE MAYOR AGREES.
>> THIS IS AFFECTING THEIR
FUTURE.
WE'VE GOT TO REACH THEM.
>> Reporter: IS THERE ANY EXCUSE
FOR ANY SCHOOL DISTRICT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY RIGHT NOW NOT TO BE
OFFERING SOME FORM OF IN-PERSON
LEARNING BY NOW?
>> THERE'S NO EXCUSE TO NOT
OFFER IN-PERSON LEARNING AT THIS
POINT.
WE'VE PROVEN THAT YOU CAN CREATE
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS THAT
WORK IN ANY CLASSROOM.
>> Reporter: De BLASIO SAYS
THOSE STANDARDS ALLOWED THE CITY
TO RESTART IN-PERSON LEARNING
ACROSS THE ENTIRE NEW YORK CITY
PUBLIC SCHOOL SYSTEM.
IT INCLUDES A RIGOROUS TESTING
PROGRAM.
EACH WEEK A RANDOM COLLECTION OF
STUDENTS AND STAFF ARE TESTED AT
EVERY NEW YORK CITY PUBLIC
SCHOOL.
20% OF EVERY SCHOOL'S POPULATION
IS TESTED MONTHLY.
HOW BIG OF A ROLE DID TESTING
PLAY IN YOUR ABILITY TO REOPEN?
>> TESTING BECAME THE GUARANTOR.
THAT GAVE CONFIDENCE TO
EVERYONE.
OUR EDUCATORS, OUR STAFF, OUR
PARENTS, EVERYONE COULD SEE
THERE WAS REALLY QUICK, RIGOROUS
FOLLOWUP WHEN THERE WAS A
PROBLEM.
>> Reporter: THAT PANDEMIC
RESPONSE LAB RUNS 125,000 P CPC
TESTS PER MONTH AND COULD DO SO
MUCH MORE ACCORDING TO CEO
JOHNATHAN BRENNAN-BADAL.
>> SCHOOL STUDENTS K THROUGH 12
IN THE METRO AREA EVERY WEEK.
>> Reporter: EVERY WEEK YOU CAN
TEST EVERY STUDENT IN A PUBLIC
SCHOOL?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
REGIME THE TECHNOLOGY IS KNOWN
AS POOL TESTING, PLACING UP TO
25 SAMPLES IN SINGLE TUBES AND
TESTING 25 PEOPLE FOR THE PRICE
OF ONE.
IF A POOL COMES BACK POSITIVE,
EACH INDIVIDUAL SAMPLE IS THEN
TESTED AGAIN ON ITS OWN TO FIND
THE POSITIVE CASES.
BUT FOR IT TO BE VIABLE AND
EFFECTIVE, THE POSITIVITY RATE
IN THE COMMUNITY NEEDS TO BE
BELOW 5%.
IN NEW YORK CITY, IT ISN'T
THERE.
STILL MORE TESTING SHOULD HELP
STUDENTS LIKE MERIL GET BACK TO
SCHOOL AND BACK TO BEING KIDS
AGAIN.
>> ONE YEAR AGO, WHEN WE LEFT
THE BUILDING AND WE REALIZED SO
MANY PEOPLE ARE DYING, I FELT
LIKE I WAS BECOMING AN ADULT
EVEN THOUGH I WAS ONLY 16 YEARS
OLD.
>> Reporter: YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'VE HAD TO GROW UP FAST.
>> YES.
>> Reporter: MERIL TEXTED ME SHE
IS ON HER WAY, AND SHE'S REALLY,
REALLY EXCITED.
ONE THING THAT STANDS OUT ABOUT
THE TEST AT THE PANDEMIC
RESPONSE LAB IS THAT IT'S
DESIGNED FOR STUDENTS TO SWAB
THEMSELVES BY SWIRLING A QTIP AT
THE BOTTOM OF THEIR NOSE.
THE COMPANY PLANS TO EXPAND TO
SEATTLE, L.A., AND D.C.
AS FOR NEW YORK CITY SCHOOLS,
MAYOR BILL De BLASIO SAYS HIS
GOAL IS TO OPEN ALL OF THEM FIVE
DAYS A WEEK BY SEPTEMBER.
ANTHONY?
>> AN AMBITIOUS GOAL.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GREAT --
>> YOU HAVE A TEACHER IN THE
HOUSE.
>> THIS HAS BEEN ROUGH FOR
EVERYBODY.
BEEN ROUGH FOR THE STUDENTS.
BEEN ROUGH FOR THE KIDS.
CERTAINLY BEEN ROUGH FOR THE
PARENTS.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF BUMPY
SPOTS ALONG THE WAY HERE IN NEW
YORK.
>> IF I WAS A KID AND COULDN'T
GO TO SCHOOL, I WOULD BE -- I
LOVED GOING TO SCHOOL AND BEING
AROUND OTHER PEOPLE.
>> YEAH.
>> ABOUT KIDS TESTING
THEMSELVES.
>> THAT WOULD MAKE ME NERVOUS.
>> WORRIED ABOUT THAT.
>> I WOU